il était attendu de pied ferme 5h45
heure locale emmanuel macron vient
d'arriver à l'aéroport de pointe-à-pitre
il est accueilli par la délégation
guadeloupéenne à ses côtés les ministres
de l'éducation de la santé jean michel
blanquer et agnès buzyn le chef de
l'état venu afficher le soutien de la
communauté nationale emmanuel macron
n'est pas venu les mains vides à bord de
l'avion présidentiel 12 tonnes de
matériels de la nourriture des
médicaments et une vingtaine d'experts
en assurance urbanisme architecture
premier point de situation avec les
autorités locales
objectif gérer l'urgence et commencer au
plus vite le travail de reconstruction
les populations en plein doute à la nuit
face aux journalistes le chef de l'état
souhaite exprimer un message de
solidarité et présenter des mesures
concrètes pour un retour au plus vite à
la vie normale
nous allons accélérer coordonner le
déblaiement des rues
le déblaiement des maisons le retour
justement aux accès minimum aux
infrastructures et la distribution
d'alimentation et dos après un vol de
reconnaissance au dessus de saint martin
le président de la république a prévu de
s'entretenir avec les forces
opérationnelles
emmanuel macron doit rencontrer cet
après midi pour la première fois les
sinistrés de l'ouragan et répondre aux
critiques et aux doléances de ces
populations privées encore de moyens de
communication d'eau potable et
d'électricité
il se rendra dans la soirée sur l'île de
saint-barthélémy